yeah
god
baby job
please no
you're an american correct
yes the land of the free yeah
yes oh yeah why why don't you have a
bunch of weird laws then
oh we do actually have a bunch of weird
laws maybe not so free after all eh
well it depends on how you ask because
now that i'm living in australia you
know
apparently i've been disowned from some
been some american's eyes i don't know
oh yeah
yeah oh you should i can't believe you
left well anyway okay do you know any
weird laws that exist like in america
like anything top top on the top of the
tongue
can i yeah i do know one uh it is
yeah it's one about uh
sodomy you know it's illegal what is
sodomy oh
oh google it oh
what the [ __ ] is this it's a bunch of
angels and babies
and babies yeah what are they doing here
look at that picture down there at the
bottom the very bottom on the right
what is this
yeah that should be illegal i don't know
what the hell
jesus christ what's wrong with you it's
it's boot sex boot sex
oh
i got it all right you know what let's
let's see what other weird lawson our
god damn i'm weirded out
ice cream or something on sunday but i
don't remember where that one is wait
what say that again it's illegal to eat
ice cream on sunday in some state i
don't remember which one it's illegal
illegal eat ice cream you're going to
jail bang bang bang kind of illegal or
just yeah
well i mean if you try to resist yes
all right let's see what weird loss
alabama alabama's gotta have good ones
big mustache and church that makes
people laugh that can't be it
what if it doesn't make what if it
doesn't make people laugh is it okay
then roll tide baby alabama
kind of get it you're not supposed to
wear silly stuff in church i get it yeah
it's a serious serious place but you're
a lot of serious stuff happens but
you're uh
what do you mean
whatever i get this one this is fine i'm
fine with this yeah this is illegal what
do you think the senate should be if you
make someone laugh wearing this
church kill him kill him
send jesus kamehameha on him
he comes down
all right we got 50 to play with it so
you can't wake up a sleeping bear to
take a photo well yeah because you'll
die
yeah that's for your own safety i
understand that one oh that's the that's
the flag of alaska that's so cool in
arizona it's illegal to let a donkey
sleep in a bath but what's what's wrong
with america ken
you know the thing you like to consider
is that
something had to happen
yeah that's what i meant that's what i
do
who did this who are you
you [ __ ] that up for everyone
this is illegal
this can't happen again never again
a bathtub is ruined
oh
no
in arkansas you can't honk your car horn
near a sandwich shop after 9pm who did
this who did this someone must have done
it so badly but they had to change law
you know how much it takes to change the
laws we can't change anything hey it's
impossible yeah that's probably why
these walls are still there because they
just can't change them oh my gosh it's
like someone's like hey
bb
yo hey yo give me a sandwich
hey look at me can i get
no it's illegal for you to do this stop
it
california if a frog dies during a frog
jumping contest it is illegal to eat
that what
don't eat the frog contestants obviously
but yes they do have a frog jumping that
seems awesome i think i've watched the
netflix show about that they like jump
down behind it and scream at it and
they breed their frogs and everything
eugenics with the frog legs they've got
some strong legs the california what is
this algebra
algebra oh yeah there's the guy down on
the left down there he's what is that
frog's killing why is he screaming at it
yeah you gotta make him kind of make him
jump you can scare him damn look at
those legs boy that's some freaking
legeronies yeah i think the rule is you
get like three lunges or two lunges and
yells at the frogs
that's all you can do this is me
screaming at you in the end it's the
furthest there's me screaming at you in
the intro of the video yeah and i jump
just like that in colorado you are not
allowed to keep a couch on your porch
that seems like a very american thing
that they took you to are you offended
by this i don't understand the whole
porch thing why do everyone want to
stare at everyone in america right why
do you want it i want the backyard not
the front porch i mean there's not much
going on it's a small community you got
to sit on the front porch and look
around see who's driving around and see
if there's someone that ain't supposed
to be around they ain't from these parts
you know you gotta go out there oh my
god is that really some sort of
checking around i don't know why people
even keep couches on their porch to
begin with because you know there's a
bunch of spiders in those cushions yeah
i don't like it in connecticut a pickle
cannot legally be called a pickle unless
it bounces why is this like a one state
thing this should be all across america
all across the world really how do you
know if it's a pickle otherwise
you don't well i had two pickles i threw
one down and just smashed a little the
ground so that was like
not a pickle obviously but if a pickle
cannot be a pickle unless it bounces how
can you call it a pickle before you try
to bounce it that's true oh my goodness
in delaware i can't wait for mississippi
to show up
please give me some horrible yeah what
do you think
mississippi's like number one and
everything bad like every everything
they come out with what's the fattest
what's the most statement obesity
cases per capita mississippi
[Laughter]
they win at everything who's the dumbest
mississippi
in delaware it's illegal to sell dogs
sam okay we did it someone's business
was ruined in florida if you tie an
elephant to a parking meter you have to
pay the same parking meter dues that you
would with a car that makes sense an
elephant dude you ever did the florida
man challenge
no you type in uh you just google
florida man and then put your birthday
in like not the not the year but just
your day
that's so good florida man let's go i've
seen this guy
yeah yeah
there's that many florida man news are
you kidding me uh
look at mom go type in florida man and
then september 21st
yeah yeah
some dude just call his whole family on
fire my birthday he's like hurry blow
your candles out anyway it's just an
interesting thing to do because there's
so many floor-to-man articles that you
can type in your birthday and fun at
least you're not in florida you have to
pay your parking for your elephant
georgia you can't keep an ice cream cone
in your back pocket on sundays maybe
this was it maybe it's not you can't eat
ice cream you just can't keep it in your
back pocket oh that would be so good i
would love to break this law if i ever
go to georgia on a sunday you know i'm
gonna do that
he's gonna you need no i'm grabbing a
sandwich right in the back i gotta get
five of them and just like yeah
go in front of the cops and be like what
are you gonna do
start twerking from you yeah
[Laughter]
who puts their [ __ ] ice cream in
their back pocket who would ever think
of that
it's illegal nobody now
because of lots
that's why it's been subconsciously
added into my morals some things not to
do
in hawaii it is illegal to stick a coin
in your ear good i always hated that
magic trick i can hear my ear now by the
way i was deaf last time we recorded i
can hear i went to the doctor and they
got like a big syringe of warm water and
squirted my ear and a big blob oh she
showed it to me he's like look at this
i'm like god that's gross that was in my
ear and then i felt dizzy
oh god
bro that's disgusting
yeah what was the blob what kind of bob
was it it was earwax like oh
my i got like i don't know from wearing
headphones i guess and having waxy ears
i took a shower yeah and i was like oh
my ears stopped up let me get a q-tip
and you know try to clear it out yeah
it's packed yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that that's the thing you're not
actually supposed to use this to clean
your ears
it literally it even says
yeah it says on them like don't use the
clean ears i'm like what the [ __ ] am i
supposed to use then what am i supposed
to use
what the [ __ ] is the q-tip box what are
you talking about the only thing you're
supposed to
to clean your ears with you can't clean
your ears with well what the [ __ ]
what a terrible life oh man yeah yeah
you gotta be real careful with that okay
well i'm glad you got it out thanks i
got a mold after my ears because i made
custom headphones once and she was like
then these are the cleanest ears
i've ever seen don't because you
shouldn't have to clean them before so i
was like what is it that's a
that's a weird compliment
your ears are so clean yeah should i get
up in your ear and be like yeah let me
just
feels good when they pour the wax or
whatever mold in your ear and goes all
the way
what are you talking about they took a
mole to your ears for what for
headphones custom headphones are you
wearing them no i i broke them it was
not worth the effort
wow yeah that's pretty fancy okay i want
fantastic guy ken
were they good that's what i want to
know were they worth getting your ears
molded the thing was they were amazing
but you know when the wife wants to ask
you something right even though you
clearly have earphones in to take them
out like imagine that they go inside
your entire ear canal to take them out
because you can't hear anything even if
it's paused so you pull them out it's
like
oh sorry i forgot what i wanted to ask
oh cool
no bueno no plan i got the open back
headphones so you can just walk in the
room and talk to me and i can hear you
it's supposed to give you a better
audience here if you have though so good
for you is it illegal to give someone a
box of chocolates weighing more than 50
pounds i don't believe that's an
american rule
it should be illegal not to give us
something
like less than 50 pounds what do you
mean
in illinois it's illegal to fall asleep
in a cheese what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
illinois
what do you mean what happens if you
fall asleep you go to jail
you wake up in prison imagine finding
yourself in a cheese shop and you're
like oh my god
i'm a little sleepy
bare hands or a firearm in iowa it is
illegal for one-armed piano players to
charge money for their performances
what
why not
oh dude you got you got one iron get the
[ __ ] got it you're not good enough what
a weird law that one makes sense they're
probably playing terribly
right how dare they how dare they not be
inclusive
yeah everybody should get paid that's
true you can sell them while they're
down true they already have one arm
let's give them a little bit more money
you'd think why why if i didn't have
vocal cords to leave the commentary to
us you know he's just boy if i don't
vocal cord should you pay me or sing nah
i don't think so dumb idea what poorly
phrased law that states if two trains
meet on the same track neither shall
proceed until the other has passed what
that's
strange should be philosophical if two
trains will meet on the same track
hmm that's yeah that's deep so they just
stop no no one goes anywhere they can't
pass
because i gotta stop okay yeah that
makes sense
yeah
dyed baby chicks
good good
tell them i had bad baby chicks really
yeah yeah i got four of them they
followed me around everywhere it was
great and then the cat ate them was
horrible it's a neighbor's cat too screw
that [ __ ] that k
in louisiana it's illegal to send a
pizza to someone else's house without
their knowledge
you know this is prank call it's like
gone too far right that's definitely
what what is on this pizza right here
this is offensive to me what is some
prosciutto and cola with some parmigiano
but what's the what's the green stuff i
don't understand
what is that well some it's rookie less
solid but i think some people call it
roque what is this a sound oh i oh sorry
and i got your joke and now i now i get
i get the joke and that you're hilarious
it's hilarious yeah thank you
it's actually not that bad but it also
makes no sense like bro i'm having a
pizza it's the same with burger like
putting a bunch of vegetables in i'm
like bro it's a burger what are you
gonna do oh my god in maine you can't
keep up christmas decorations after good
good i hate it put down your [ __ ]
thing you're disrespecting christmas
good good man
that's not a weird law that's a good law
everywhere long we've already had the
discussion about like when you put your
christmas yeah and it should be illegal
to put them up too early too yeah yeah
okay yeah so taking them down if you put
them up before and you're worried 14. if
you put them up before october 31st you
go to i think death sentence i'm
thinking like a banish to an island
maybe
i'm gonna you banish them to christmas
island oh no not anywhere but there it's
no that's in the australian island it's
australia yeah why why do you have that
why do you have this terrible plane
yo
you gotta get crazy you gotta fight off
all the crabs is that where that
didn't did did it did it
but there's nothing happy happening
there right no just
oh my god imagine waking up seeing this
yeah looks like a dog too that's kind of
funny
right nothing
it's bad what is bad about it what is it
christmas island yeah unless i'm
thinking about the wrong place it's like
whenever immigrants come over like
legally or whatever into australia and
they just like put them over there in
like camps
like get rid of them and just put them
over there were they a bunch of crabs
they are now all right all right 14th
this is hilarious i love this you just
have police come in knocking on people's
doors yes yes yes january 15th we're
gonna have to i'm gonna have to take you
oh my god don't don't ridicule the laws
with your hypotheticals okay no yeah
stop that's what we do all right
the new year new us yeah number 20. in
maryland though outdated it is still
technically illegal to wear sleeveless
shirts in public
wait what you're not allowed to wear a
tank though
no sleeveless shirts good v-necks are
okay though yeah oh god wait that's the
second stage
vote pewdiepie i'll fix it for you guys
no v-necks
you're gonna be president you're gonna
fix it no mispronunciation of host
covarna
all right okay you're going to jump so
many comments in that video everybody
like it's husqvarna no you're going to
jail
you can't own an explosive golf ball
that makes sense
yeah on an explosive golf ball in
michigan women are not technically
allowed to cut their own hair without
their husbands oh that's f dude michigan
get the [ __ ] out of here
this lady actually cut her hair for this
clip they're using oh my god that's
dedication send her to jail hold there
lady you got your husband's permission
for that
uh hohoho i need a written permission
slip from your husband the man of the
house where is he
in minnesota contest where the point is
to catch a greased or oiled pig are
illegal yeah good poor peggy's in
mississippi
church service my homeland listeners are
allowed may be encouraged to perform as
citizens yeah
exactly
as soon as that
is dude that makes sense you know you
bust up in church and interrupt all of a
sudden everybody's pulling their guns
yeah yeah
[Applause]
yeah why
he's wearing a mustache too and it's
funny
shoot him
make me laugh
yeah i thought it was gonna be something
worse honestly yeah i wonder if there's
any weird laws in in sweden is it legal
for a woman to marry a tree good good
because it gets law for a parent to
shame their child and it's also illegal
it's against the law to shame a child
how do you race them
you have to destroy them you have to
destroy their confidence to its core
with nothing but shame and pain
how else they learn
they've always happened naturally for me
trying to raise them they're just like
oh my god you're embarrassing me maybe
you think you can does that mean you can
sue your parents than when you grow up
and like you
shamed me when i ate from cookie
all right what else we got is illegal to
paint your house without a license first
yeah yeah yeah
good i always thought that was good we
actually taught about that in school
really yeah because it's like you're not
supposed we we're all about everyone
being the same you can't be that one
house on the street with a pink house
like get the daddy here yeah it's
illegal to spontaneously dance bruh no
campaign
[Laughter]
that is not a law spontaneously dance
get out of here i don't know if people
are just making this up here i got a uh
here's another law right here maybe you
can read this to me it's illegal to name
your baby
it's pronounced albin
that means someone tried all right maybe
maybe there's more uh mississippi loss
in here makes you watch
my dream that's my american dream my bro
you ain't sitting isn't arresting
anybody get out of here
it's illegal to drive with an uncaged
bear
that's good that's probably good in
montana putting an animal on railroad
tracks with the intent of harming the
train or the tracks is punishable by a
fifty thousand dollar fine or five years
in prison okay that makes sense
what pictures of dogs and stuff what is
that gonna do to the train if they put
animals in front of it to harass but
yeah it makes sense like maybe they're
like cows or stuff like like big animals
but yeah and a little little puppy dog
gonna do it's a good smell
boy the cow don't get smashed half that
cow cows are evil all right you're the
one that told me that cows are eating
they are killed they kill a lot of
people it's not talked about enough
we gotta we gotta let everybody know
cows man they're murderers they kill
except the indians cast they're
wonderful
and nebraska is illegal for people with
stds to get married
huh
okay stds to get married in nevada it's
unlawful to drive a camel down a highway
oh what there's no fun anymore eh eh no
no fun to be had
collect or carry away seaweed at night
at night huh okay what about during the
day it's all fair game but that night
you ain't carrying that the swamp
monster's gonna come out and get you or
something
that's gonna happen
oh god it's illegal for men to knit
during the fishing oh wow that's so mean
well let them knit if they want to
well i gotta knit some mittens you know
cuz
what's going on
probably some [ __ ] lawmaker who
wanted to [ __ ] up his friend like who
jerry who loves to knit or something
yeah he already needed me and i'll show
him i show that son hey jerry it's
illegal no
you're going to let g you're going to
wait a long time jerry we finally got
here
he's always also the only guy that ever
went to jail for it
you can hit him princess [ __ ]
oh it's fantastic
new mexico the state is over 400 words
removed from romeo and juliet which part
being a little bit too unsafe which part
it is illegal
i don't remember there being you know
400 words in total in romeo and juliet
right didn't they just like show up and
i love you
maybe we got the censored version maybe
this is way more awesome version oh
the unsavory version all right it's
illegal take picture okay that makes
sense
in north carolina it is illegal to use
elephants to plow cotton fields
what it's illegal to lie down and fall
asleep with your stop it north dakota do
or just that's mean this is mean
i'm falling asleep
why am i netting they're infections like
as well
someone said i just ordered a pizza for
someone who didn't tell them
and there i got seaweed and it's night
time
time but i'm driving my camel down the
street
no i'm crying about it but it's church
and now i'm interested
in mississippi
oh god
i'm going away for such a long time
i'm so illegal
damn in ohio you can't get a fish drunk
i don't know what man
i'm a pescatarian i would never do that
you can't make glue out of dead skunks
what what
how do you make glue
i was a glue maid i always hear the
stuff about turning horses in the glue
wait what glue that's the thing what are
they doing seriously you make them into
glue maybe you just glue them down like
really smash them and then they start
getting sticky yeah i guess anything you
smash it enough it gets sticky wow
you know
smash that like button hey thanks
pennsylvania it's illegal to catch a
fish with you what
can't stop me who dude was doing that
who made it illegal god dang jerry he's
a monster
illegal
you're going to present damn
it's time for you [ __ ] show up you
and your mittens oh it's i think it's a
all right well that makes sense horses
on the highway but if you do it's only a
twenty dollars
yeah
they should make freaking cyclists
illegal that's what they should oh my
god yes you hate cyclists too every like
dude i don't know how there are cyclists
because everybody hates them oh okay i
thought it was just me
oh this is amazing oh
what's wrong with these people on the
road
they're like they own the whole thing
you have a bike lane you idiot every
time
you care swear to god it was so awkward
i was getting so angry at one and we had
friends in the car and i i don't know
like they didn't they weren't vibing
with how angry i was and then i was like
damn i guess well if the bike lanes too
narrow they have to ride side by side so
they can talk while they're swerving all
over the place and then oh my god and
then the logic is like oh well you know
if it wasn't for me the savior and the
bike there would be another car on the
road
yeah give me another car on the road
please i don't know jog or something
come run
there's a park near here like it's a
huge park it's called centennial park
there's cyclists that just like run
around this thing all the time i have to
like grab my kids and like dodge them
like i'm playing frogger because they're
so they just don't care they will just
run you over and your entire family
screw them they're stupid spandex
looking smelly stuff they're wearing if
there's a hell they are going to it the
cyclist yeah yeah
if you're watching this right now and
your dad's a cyclist just go slap him
for me
you're a cyclist
but they also refuse to break right
because they built up all this momentum
so even though they are supposed to stop
they're like no i'm committing and you
can never [ __ ] hear them too wow i
wonder why they are the way they are you
think it's because they are exercising
and they're miserable yeah that they
just don't care about anybody else
probably there's some deep psychological
freudian happening there a man over 16
can't seduce a woman by lying and saying
he'll marry her women can't do it to men
though not fair it's not fair casinos
are not allowed if women have to have
permission to cut their hair i think
it's fair that they get that one right
okay yeah
i don't remember what it was because
yeah
casinos are not allowed to have signs
that say that makes sense
look like you walk in ah yeah i'm going
down here to the
all you can eat buffet oh it's a casino
whoa
i
never guessed that
well i don't think we're allowed to have
a casino either in uk actually
science is sick it's called like fun
time slots or some [ __ ] i don't know
well maybe that's the thing and i'll
show you where it's like the vip lounge
yeah yeah there you go there's a slots
oh you can't share your netflix packs
that's a new one then what the [ __ ] well
that's isn't it against the terms of
service why just tennessee
why just tennessee out of old places i
mean you know that freaking freaking
jerry over there sharing and giving away
his netflix to everyone and then he gave
it to too many people and he could only
have 10. how are they going to check
that like what
the lawmaker couldn't watch his shows
because too many people had logged in
use the same password and he got married
like this isn't enough enough's enough
oh this is illegal oh god in texas dude
it's unlocked to sell a human eye oh
yeah yeah that's unlawful everywhere
what are you talking about in texas i
don't know apparently not apparently not
it we don't finally mississippi you
gonna go over to mississippi are those
your eyes
or someone else's huh
yeah i'm going down to pawn shop to sell
old jim bob's eyes here you know
it's a league to ride a bike without at
least one hand on the handlebars to
write it ah
what the song oh my god the song utah
has fun apparently what the [ __ ] it had
to be illegal
in vermont women need permission from
their husbands again to wear fake teeth
makes sense i don't want my wife pulling
up with fake teeth without telling me
she better not have to see better
hair or do whatever the other thing was
we'll see the things she had to do for
him
outside of marriage is still illegal in
washington state should you be the
person to confirm the existence of the
species
it is illegal to harass or kill bigfoot
or sasquatch i'm gonna harass him i'm
gonna ask him some questions hey
why took you so long where how are you
where do you think you're going you're
going to me with me in the cage
oh dude there's a show uh it's called
what is it called
mountain monsters where they go hunt
sasquatch and there's one that
he can he has mind control powers oh
that makes sense he can control you yeah
it's
it's totally real sounds real that means
washington state confirms that sasquatch
is real
virginia it's illegal to whistle
underwater can't stop me cannot stop me
cops pull up with a snorkel
start shooting you with uh harpoons
who is this magical man that was
whistling in the water that guy's
illegal [ __ ] jerry man you guys hey
jerry's fishing didn't get his mittens
on he's whistling
underwater you can do it all
wisconsin's butter substitutes can't be
served at a restaurant unless people
specifically ask oh
that's not fake butter this
is going to prison
i didn't ask for this i have been
accosted sir
last but not least we have number 50
every day it is illegal to take a
picture of a rabbit from january to
april without a permit all right oh wow
incredible what a country what a current
word place what a goofy blue place you
know what else should be legal not
subscribing to this channel and cans for
that matter check that link description
and the video thank you for watching
there's your birthday birthday
i was gonna scream too scary but i'm not
gonna do it that's why oh thank you i
thought you were waiting on me
sorry
i had to do it you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator
add some of our patented stickers in
there stickers our emotions memes our
emotions
express your emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this